[Applaudissements]
osons j'ai osé mettre une slide avec le
tête toc New York 2022 parce que 85% des
gens regardent les vidéos sur YouTube
sans le son donc ça risque de me faire
des vues en plus et il y a pas de petits
profits
et d'ailleurs si on me demande de faire
un tecto à New York et bien comme ça
j'ai déjà la slide qui est prête
mais osez c'est toute ma vie moi j'avais
un Meetic j'adorais et que je suis
rêvait de faire depuis l'âge de 4 ans
j'avais un public acquis conquis captif
jeune
j'avais un métier stable enfin si je
trucider pas des bambins j'avais un
salaire de ministre enfin ça dépend du
pays dans lequel on vit j'avais 14
semaines de vacances j'étais
institutrice et j'ai osé tout plaquer
sur un ouais sur un coup de tête j'ai
pas réfléchi j'ai j'ai foncé et j'ai
pris une décision rapide instinctive
comme ça en deux ans d'année sa bâti
j'ai passé de ça
à ça
les images parlent d'elle-même j'ai
coupé mes cheveux qui était l'élément
l'accessoire obligatoire pour être une
maîtresse d'école primaire
alors évidemment avec les crocs
mais en gros voilà moi j'ai passé
d'humoriste à institutrice et grâce à
ses décisions ce soir je suis même en
train de faire un TEDx à Martigny
enfin presque
donc moi dans ma vie je me demande
toujours enfin je suis toujours
impressionnée quand il y a des gens qui
justement quittent leur métier pour
vivre de leur passion et je me suis
toujours demandé si moi mon petit niveau
j'impressionné aussi des gens à part ma
maman
qui me rappelle régulièrement quand même
qu'institutrice c'était un super métier
qu'elle aurait bien voulu le faire et
que c'est un métier stable que je
pouvais retrouver parce que j'avais
toujours le diplôme
alors c'est vrai que quand j'ai
osé venir et dire oui au tedex et ben en
fait j'ai osé un petit peu trop vite
parce que j'aurais mieux fait de
réfléchir et surtout de demander la
liste des orateurs parce que je trouve
que ce soir on avait vraiment du lourd
c'était impressionnant on a commencé à
Yoann tennis Yohan ténesi c'est un
neuroscientifique lui il a osé il se
pose des questions que personne
n'oserait se poser
il a dit lui la question qui se pose et
qui laisserait aussi c'est qu'est-ce
qu'une banane
bon c'est dommage parce qu'il m'aurait
demandé je leur ai expliqué
[Applaudissements]
après on a eu Gabrielle binder qui s'est
préoccupé de la généalogie moi ce que
j'ai trouvé
osé j'ai Gabriel binder c'est c'est
slides
non mais j'ai trouvé ça magique et je me
suis dit tiens est-ce qu'il a pris trois
mois comme un artiste pour préparer ses
slides poules t'aide ex ou alors quand
il a commencé ses études il semblait un
petit peu il a fait des slides après les
a regardé il a dit c'est bon là j'ai
tout et elle les accompagne
toute sa vie et il a fait ça avant
PowerPoint
après on a eu souvent de Périssé alors
on a plein de points communs avec Swan
périssés alors moi j'ai passé d'un style
à humoriste et elle elle a passé
d'humoriste à influenceuse et je vous
dis plein de points communs j'ai vu elle
a elle l'a dit elle a environ un million
de followers moi pareil
fin grosso modo puis on n'est pas à un
million près
et puis elle a dit elle est finalement
une humoriste engagée aujourd'hui alors
pareil que moi un mois souvent je suis
engagée alors pas pour une cause mais en
tant qu'humoriste
et puis je me suis dit ben elle est
influenceuse j'ai envie de la suivre
mais maintenant je sais qu'elle a fait
un mois de vélo je pense pas que je vais
réussir à la suivre
et surtout ce qui est là aux affaires
pendant son temps c'est quand elle s'est
mise
elle a dit ben voilà elle partage
c'était un moment qui était alors je
dirais pas un moment de solitude mais
c'est c'était un moment important pour
elle elle nous l'a expliqué
et elle nous a surtout expliqué que
2,5% des gens qui écoutaient une
influenceuse
donc ce soir potentiellement j'ai juste
une petite mise en garde parce qu'à peu
près 2,5% parmi nous
alors je rappelle que c'est pas sur la
route mais sous un arbre
ensuite il y a eu Cyrus phase elle alors
pilule rouge pilule bleue alors autant
j'ai aimé autant j'ai eu un petit peu
peur et et je dois vous annoncer qu'il y
a peu de chances que vous qu'on se
retrouve dans la métaverse parce qu'en
fait moi dans la vie réelle quand je
mets des lunettes de réalité augmentée
enfin dans la vie des réels je souffre
de cinétose c'est-à-dire le mal des
transports justement avec les lunettes
de réalité augmentée je suis malade donc
je vais pas vous rejoindre dans la
métaverse après on a eu cil qui est pan
incroyable alors déjà je savais pas que
Peter avait une sœur
mais surtout elle nous a dit voilà moi
j'ai trouvé que ces châteaux de sable à
elle bah c'est des châteaux forts et je
trouve que quand Cécile qui nous dit de
mettre un pas devant l'autre pour
avancer ça vraiment un poids énorme on
peut encore l'applaudir
alors qu'on m'a dit Frédéric Favre j'ai
cru que ça la plrib bon ça c'est très
Martigny comme solution c'est pas le bon
pardon ah voilà Frédéric Favre la poésie
Denis alors moi au début je pensais que
c'était un pays la poésie Donnie et puis
finalement il nous a dit que c'est une
plante à fleurs alors moi mon niveau je
veux aussi aider notre planète donc je
veux aller acheter un bouquet de fleurs
mais par contre il a très peu parlé du
problème de trouver un fleuriste pour la
posidonie donc je pense ça va me poser
quelques problèmes et enfin Pascal
critin il a parlé de la crise alors moi
je pensais qu'il allait plutôt parler de
la crise nobilag 1 nobilight 2 nobilight
3 et s'il avait parlé de ça bah j'aurais
pu lui rassurer en dirant en lui disant
que quand une crise est récurrente c'est
plus une crise ça devient la routine
donc moi j'ai vu tous ces gens puis je
me suis dit mais qu'est-ce que j'ai osé
faire moi dans ma vie à part abandonner
des gosses
non mais c'était pas les miens en plus
donc
et j'ai demandé au organisateurs
pourquoi vous avez pensé à moi et là ils
m'ont répondu Cendrine pendant la
pandémie on a vu en 2020 tu as
osé très vite tu as fait un truc de fou
en tant qu'artiste tu as
osé faire le pique-nique tour
alors c'est vrai que dit comme ça c'est
pas super impressionnant
mais si vous voulez que mon 2020 et ben
moi je pouvais plus faire rentrer des
spectateurs dans les théâtres j'ai
décidé de les faire sortir avec le
pique-nique tour en gros si vous voulez
j'ai passé de attention j'appelle mon
agent parce que j'arrive bientôt au
théâtre puis je lui demande est-ce que
tu as contrôlé que les bouteilles de
blanc sont bien au frais donc j'ai passé
de ça à mettre des bouteilles de blanc
fraîches dans tous les sacs des
spectateurs pour leur faire des
pique-niques des sacs à pique-nique et
ça c'était osé parce que je suis nul en
cuisine et je peux vous dire que même
pour faire des pique-niques pour les
autres surtout c'est la catastrophe
alors le pique-nique tour qu'est-ce que
c'est ben c'est un concept très simple
c'était un spectacle un lieu insolite et
un pique-nique alors le spectacle moi je
l'écrivais pour l'été pour expliquer
c'est un peu comme une revue estivale
j'expliquais ce qu'on vivait et puis
c'était fait pour un petit nombre de
spectateurs pour que les gens soient
safe en pleine nature avec comme décor
justement le lieu insolite et le nombre
de spectateurs en Suisse a varier selon
le canton la météo ou l'humeur de notre
ministre de la Culture Alain Berset
Alain Berset qui ensuite on a une seule
personne que ministre de la Culture et
ministre de la Santé alors là les
pessimiste se dit la culture est malade
mais les positif comme moi on dit que
rire c'est bon pour la santé
donc moi j'ai sorti les gens et je me
suis mise à nu enfin façon de parler à
nu parce que je voulais quand même
garder les gens
mais fondamentalement moi si je fais des
one man show aujourd'hui c'est que
secrètement je nourris l'espoir qu'un
jour je pourrais jouer devant des
milliers de personnes dans des stades
avec des écrans LED géants de la
pyrotechnique des chevaux des avatars de
moi en 3D et Florence Foresti en
première partie
et je me suis retrouvée sans lumière
sans son sans filet les yeux dans les
yeux avec le public et ben ça a été
extraordinaire et ça crée quelque chose
que j'aurais jamais pu créer dans une
salle de spectacle et surtout le côté
pique-nique ça donnait un côté fun et ça
a amené des gens il serait pas venu
forcément dans des salles de spectacle
j'ai eu des familles qui sont venus
faire les huit entends de la Nonna ou
bien les 20 ans du petit des
pique-niques en amoureux et j'ai tissé
un lien alors que je suis timide parce
que là vraiment j'avais pas les jingles
ou les changements de lumière pour
reprendre mon souffle et reprendre mes
esprits comme on le fait dans un
spectacle sur une scène
et du coup ça fait tellement bien marché
qu'avec mon équipe on a réfléchi pour
voir si on pouvait amener un petit peu
plus loin cette idée parce que c'est
vrai que ça fait trois ans qu'on le fait
ça marche bien et finalement bon la
première année c'est vrai qu'à un moment
donné j'ai eu un comme un petit moment
de vide quand j'étais face aux gens sans
artifice je me suis dit bon bah c'est
dommage parce que là si j'étais toujours
instit en ce moment je serai en train de
donner mes cours en pyjama devant mon
écran
et du coup on s'est dit qu'on allait
pousser un petit peu plus loin ce côté
sympa du pique-nique et on a créé le
hashtag pique-nique alors le hashtag
pique-nique je vous parlais d'écran
c'est une vidéo courte qui présente de
façon humoristique une région ces
personnalités ces spécialités il a
actuellement en train de finir de filmer
les dernières capsules s’appelle les
capsules vidéos et c'est vrai que je
rencontre des gens super je vais dans
des lieux en Suisse où j'étais jamais
allé j'ai même rencontré des Suisses
allemands ça veut dire si je sors de ma
zone de confort
la semaine prochaine je vais tourner
dans l'Emmental j'espère pas tomber dans
un trou
ça veut dire bonjour
alors que Yolo
ça veut dire à table
et Yolo ça veut dire attention il y a un
loup
qu'on traduit en Suisse romande par Pan
donc pour faire ces ce hashtag
pique-nique je le fais pas tout seul
parce que je me suis entourée d'une
super équipe donc les images sont dignes
du National Geographic c'est une super
équipe visuelle de production justement
à la production j'ai aussi des femmes
extraordinaires qui sortent un petit peu
de ce qu'on connaît et ce que je
connaissais dans mon milieu du mur je me
suis quand même entouré de deux auteurs
d'humour français et suis ce que
j'affectionne et puis actuellement bah
voilà on est en train d'essayer de
convaincre ah bah allez eux voilà de
convaincre
la RTS de diffuser ses capsules
d'ailleurs faites-moi penser
faites-moi penser de dire à Pascal
crittac j'ai adoré sa présentation
et mon secret si vous voulez oser c'est
que dans la vie il faut s'entourer de
gens qui sont meilleurs que vous mais
qui ne le savent pas
c'est ce que j'ai fait
osons et je terminerai par ces citations
je crois qu'il y a tout est dit dans la
slide je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]